[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1:
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
MALE SPEAKER 2: One of the more
exciting things about
HTML5 is the [? grapsel ?]
capability.
Using a device orientation
API I could really
shake up the world.
MALE SPEAKER 3: At Google, to
make the promise of the cloud
come true, we launched Google
App Engine two and
a half years ago.
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
MALE SPEKER 5: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
MALE SPEAKER 3: But what we've
done is we've worked on our
development tools and with
partners to enable what we
call cloud portability.
MALE SPEAKER 6: And this
is why cloud matters.
It's simply because
it will accelerate
your ability to invent.
MALE SPEAKER 6: Let's talk about
the growth of Android.
MALE SPEAKER 7: We have over 95
compatible devices at work,
across 22 manufacturers,
49 countries.
MALE SPEAKER 8:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
MALE SPEAKER 3:
MALE SPEAKER 9:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]